this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode as we've had a ton of
requests for it for a while now jonathan
is finally going to be taking a look at
the weapons of killing floor 2. this gun
shoots money i'm sure there's some deep
social commentary going on here the
velvet cheek piece with studs on it has
a very interesting real world parallel
one of henry viii's own guns that we
have we know from the stud holes that
that was originally a velvet cheap piece
if there are any other games guns
mechanics and you guys want to see
jonathan break down let us know in the
comment section below and if you'd like
to help the royal army museum and
continue to support jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
in this video right over to jonathan
hurry up all right first up we've got
the aa-12 which always irks me simply
because we haven't got one made a big
splash in pop culture generally games
films it's an automatic shotgun
especially when coupled with something
like dragon's breath or um some other
novelty round of ammunition i'm not at
all surprised that what's effectively a
zombie multiplayer shooter has an a12 in
it um so i can't do a direct comparison
on it and slavish adherence to realism
is clearly not this game's focus so a
little hard to hold unfair to hold a
game like this to the standards of
something like say tarkov which is
trying to be
as realistic as possible
i don't know what it is about the poor
old tommy gun people cannot resist
putting it in space
and this is quite a nicely done one but
uh i i'm not a fan of neon and you know
different colors and yeah not not really
my thing we just saw a round of
ammunition in the drum there for some
reason as well as the the projectile bit
having a glow to it it's got some type
of an effect the primer is also glowing
bright blue i don't know why that would
be the case it's either an energy weapon
or it's a normal projectile weapon i
would think but this appears to be a
mixture of both making a making an
energy weapon that that harks back to
the thompson i can get behind that i'm
not so big a fan of modifying
thompson to make it futuristic but
clearly it speaks to something in people
because it happens quite a bit
[Applause]
all right this is a maybe not direct
copy but very closely based on the
arsenal af 2011 which was a a bit of um
i suppose we'd probably call it now a
mean gun
i'm sure the makers wouldn't mind me
saying that and as
it kind of says on the tin it's a double
1911 pistol so two magazines i think the
base plate attaches them together a
massive double slide two barrels two
separate triggers for i think legal
reasons so you're you're pulling two
triggers at once because otherwise it'd
be two shots for it for one pull of the
trigger and therefore a machine gun in
u.s law uh completely impractical
really heavy you know what though this
thing absolutely fits with an
over-the-top supernatural first-person
shooter like this uh it could have been
made for it in fact i'm always surprised
no one invented this design in popular
culture before they did in reality um
but as far as i know arsenal came up
with the gun first and then people have
done you know used it in movies
occasionally and i don't know
it must be it must be more than just
this game but i don't remember seeing it
in anything else
watch your ears siren
got a hit on you demon
i shoot
that's a new take i think new to me
anyway on the dual wielding thing uh the
ability to fire them both classic dual
wield
back to rise of the triad and probably
probably even something earlier than
that but also to aim with one and then
be pointing in the right same rough
direction with the other don't know if
they're modeling how inaccurate the gun
in the left hand would be in that
situation and accurate with one in the
right hand if anything you'd be less
accurate with the one you're not aiming
within the left hand than would be if
you were only firing that or if you were
just firing two at the same time i don't
know uh to their credit they do depict
the reload they don't just go off camera
for it be very hard to replicate that in
real life maybe don't try it at home
mind if you have two of these things at
home you probably don't need me to tell
you what to do
for now
alright this is really cool i i like
this quite a bit though this is what we
would call a combination weapon but it
actually is reminiscent of a real world
sort of gun i'll explain in a moment so
what it really is is a sledgehammer of
whatever poundage i'm not sure it has
the action of a sledgehammer but when
you do your old fire i imagine it's got
a gun built into it so it's got a it's
even got a magazine feeding up into the
head of the sledgehammer and you can see
this the firing pill striker and the
spring on the back of the head and then
it'll have a muzzle on the front of the
of the hammer and so it fires when you
strike and then you've got uh quite a
fun
pump action to reload it now i can't
begin to imagine how that pump action
would ever really work i'd suspect the
answer is it wouldn't but it's really
cool
and the real world relevance here is
it's very similar in principle to
a type of humane killer for slaughtering
cattle or euthanasian usualizing cattle
it's a long wooden
path with a head on it's not really a
hammer it's not designed for that impact
strike uh because the idea is when it
contacts the
animal's head
it fires essentially a bolt gun so it's
a bolt gun on the end of a stick but it
works very much like this i don't know
if the developers saw that type of
killing tool i suppose you call it or if
they came up with this completely
independently which i suspect is is the
truth but um fascinating for us here at
the royal armouries because we deal with
all sorts of weapons and armor and this
is a really interesting fictional weapon
this is certainly an interesting visual
so a quad barrel shotgun quite a sci-fi
looking design probably the most
interesting thing about this for me is
the the reload so we've got the third
person view here of the reload and he's
the players cradling it in the crook of
his arm to reload it which looking at
this thing it would weigh an absolute
ton and that would probably be the only
effective way to do it they could have
fudged this and had it just had him just
hold it with one hand in midair like
arnold schwarzenegger or something and
they didn't do that they they actually
tried to think how would we reload this
if it was a real gun you'd probably put
it over your arm so i actually think
that's a somewhat realistic even if the
gun itself is implausibly massive and
heavy and the current player character
is dressed as a pseudo
late 14th century knight i think
it seems
unwise uh i actually might send some
this clip to
my counterpart in the armor edge weapons
and armor department just to see the
look of horror on his face
foul
creatures there are plenty left
looks like we've got two fire modes one
is one barrel at a time i'm not sure how
the gun would actually affect that maybe
a lancaster style rotating striker but
however it's supposed to do it it has a
secondary fire mode that fires all four
barrels at once which is tremendously
effective so at least four zombies
disappearing to a shower of gore and the
the player character actually
moves back which although like
physically moving back like that is not
of course realistic at least it does
indicate or respect physics to some
degree because that amount of mass going
that way definitely is going to push you
back what would happen in reality if the
recoil was that strong and you didn't
step back is you'd fall over backwards
just like the lights and the falcons did
the the normal black colored
glock 18c is it's pretty good it's not
spot on by any means uh the yellow
colored versions have weird cutouts on
the side of the slide that i don't think
are on the normal version so that that
presumably is a custom slide the in
general form it's it's recognizably a
glock 18c
obviously the the black and yellow
version is a is an aesthetic choice
as are the bizarre compensators that
make them look really sci-fi but yeah
they behave much like a clock 18 would i
suppose two different reloads i've seen
here there's a there's a sort of
flick out the magazine to the side
reload later on that was not the case
before that so there's some some variety
than just a stock reload animation for
everything
the glock 18c
used in concept with the right shield is
quite fun never mind spinning it around
on the trigger finger literally on the
trigger which is not a good idea
really great way to to shoot yourself
with probably more than one bullet that
side
the the reload of
flicking other magazines neither here
nor there but having somehow put in a
new magazine it would be possible
they're then
using
i think the rear sight which isn't a
great idea with stock sides because
they're plastic
they're chambering around off the side
of the shield
which i'm gonna say i've seen done but
it might have been in uh something
fictional rather than for real so i
won't commit to that but you could do it
that way there's certainly plenty of
drills where you you do it off the heel
of your boots or off your belt
the idea being if you're wounded on one
side and you have to
manage to get the magazine in you then
have to
operate it off something to get enough
travel if i didn't there to actually be
able to reload to chamber around
lever action shotgun i would absolutely
expect to be in this game and it is um i
would not have expected it to have a
what looks like a magical axe blade
attached to it now we have in the
collection uh we've i've done a video on
it on over on the royal armouries
channel you'd like to go and check that
out we have a very cool and actually
very functional danish boarding axe that
has well it is a gun it's essentially a
pistol and a boarding axe in one and as
combination weapons go it's really good
relatively light relatively effective
the gun would work quite well as a gun
blade works well
as an axe blade it was it was actually a
military service for decades as far as
we know this thing less so i don't know
i don't understand the oh it's got runes
on the on the stock slash halft
uh and the fact that it's kind of
permanently iced up tells me it's
delivering some sort of frost damage
when you strike with it the lever action
shotgun aspect not much too much to say
about that kind of know how those how
those work in games okay the loading
gate is too small loading gates need to
be long enough to actually get the
cartridge in at an angle and this is
more like just a little porthole and
they're kind of magically going in no no
visible locking system here it's so far
removed from a real lever gun i'm gonna
stop talking i think
trusty mosin mosin nagant three-line
rifle 9130 model was in 1891 when it was
originally introduced and 1930 when it
was modified into the variant that we
see
um throughout the second world war this
is a nice one because it has a sling on
it always nice to see an original sling
and
like the one i'm looking at on the
screen
it has
bayonet a very late
form of socket bayonet on the mosin
so slide it on
push against the rear sight and turn
and it latches into place the blade is
fluted to keep it light but it has a
chisel tip to it
but it's actually
sharp but it is
wide it's not an acute point now that
makes it harder to break it also makes
it harder to actually thrust through
equipment clothing and tissue then again
that's still quite a small surface area
with quite a lot of mass behind it and
it's all the technique i suppose the
thing i noticed right away about this is
as far as i know there's one standard uh
bayonet length for this pattern rifle
and this is it and it's
longer than a foot but it's not two feet
long
which is at least what the one in the
game is appearing to be to me
now let's have a look at some gameplay
gotcha
fours we've got uh a bayonet thrust
there seen from the third person view
it's not very impressive it looks like a
sort of bayonet thrust i might do
you need a bit more more of an actual
thrust going on there to actually
penetrate what you're what you're trying
to stab that was more like a theatrical
flourish really like a gentle tickle
maybe let's let's see how it works on an
actual creature
okay so we've seen several zombie type
things getting shanked there and it's
essentially a one touch kill not really
getting the the visceral sense of
bayonet combat here you know actually
being able to
strike with a sufficient force and
precision to to get any sort of
penetration and then the sort of
difficulty of having to withdraw that
point this is like you're dead you're
dead you're dead given hordes of
creatures running at you in the game
makes perfect sense but uh it's
certainly not if we're holding this to
any standard of realism that's that's
not how bayonets work um and of course
the giant gouts of blood that appear
whenever you do anything in this game
well who knows how supernatural
creatures react to getting shot and
stabbed but it's a bit jackson pollock
for me
very sci-fi this thing needless to say
it is a ballpark i'm not sure what that
uh
reflex sight on the top was doing
at the beginning of the clip where it
was motoring back and forth not really
sure why you'd do that normally you want
your sights nicely fixed in place
otherwise you lose your uh your zero i
do think it's interesting that uh sci-fi
gun designs tend toward a knuckle bow
trigger guard that encloses the hand and
i'm not
really sure why i think it's probably
about breaking up the lines of what we
know
instinctively a gun looks like if that
makes sense so you know we've gone past
the the musket and the bolt action rifle
era of a shotgun style straight stock we
still know that that means gun when we
see it but i think increasingly we
expect a pistol grip on a gun and so a
way to make it seem more futuristic is
to put that knuckle bow guard on there i
don't really know why the only real
reason for it is arctic warfare or or
any situation where you're gonna have
bulky gloves and then you can fit your
whole hand in but yeah in space
everyone's using knuckle bows
this one's quite intriguing so we we
have a
frame
a grip frame recoil shield hammer
arrangement very similar to the
percussion cults the the 1860 army or
the 1861 navy and then everything
forward of that is i think safe to say
steampunk and some sort of rocket
bullets i think before we see those in
before i talk about those in action i am
not convinced by the reload on this so
those uh those percussion cults were
open top that they connected only at the
bottom and at the axis pin running
through the middle
part part they weren't great for more
powerful ammunition that came along
later on with the cartridge
era hence why they moved to a solid
frame or if
you look at something like smith and
wesson with a break action frame they've
got some quite solid solid top strap and
a solid latching mechanism to hold that
thing together and make it robust this
has the flimsiest top strap i've ever
seen and i've no idea how that would
actually lock into place because they've
made it a break open a little bit
bunched there um it could have done away
with that top strap i've just had a
replicated percussion cult and just had
you take out the cylinder and replace it
maybe let's see how it works
yeah very much the the western trope
there in the handling of it as well
we've got uh
animations of lots of spinning the the
front end is very reminiscent of the
flamethrower we've got this ventilated
nozzle looks to be some sort of ignition
system for the rounds i'm not really
sure the rounds themselves look look to
be miniature rockets or something and
actually that that might justify the the
weak frame that i'm talking about
because if you don't have to contain
much in the way of pressure then you
wouldn't have to worry too much about
how weak your frame is at the end of the
day it's a sort of raygun inspired
incendiary cult single action army and
that's fine
all right paul's there because this has
taken me very much by surprise this gun
shoots
money
apparently i'm sure there's some deep
social commentary going on here sci-fi
design there's like a belt box carrier
that the the players are loading with
greenbacks setting that aside for a
moment the the velvet cheek piece with
studs on it has
a very interesting real world parallel
unfortunately i can't
show you at the moment i don't have one
to show but we have we have a couple of
guns
that
have padded cheek pieces and one of
henry viii's own guns that we have
that's on display down at the tower of
london sadly it's now missing but we
know from the stud holes and from the
inventory from i think 1547 that that
was originally a velvet cheek piece so
amusingly enough this very high-end rich
person's prestige gun has a distant echo
from the 16th century which is
kind of fun
so from the third person view i think i
get where they're coming from with this
i think this is a riff on the gambit
from the x-men and his ability to throw
objects notably playing cards at
effectively i guess hyper velocity such
that they're um they're very low mass
but their velocity means that they're
lethal or at least that would be a
pseudo-scientific way to explain that it
looks like here one of the bank notes is
coming out glowing and straight and
clearly with somehow enough velocity to
kill and then we have a residual effect
of a load of other notes kind of coming
out this is this is this is a very fun
weapon i have to say
another unusual one here an automatic
rifle with an underbarrel grenade
launcher specifically this underbarrel
grenade launcher which i have uh
liberated from its fn scar host weapon
and it's been changed up at the back end
to facilitate this design but it's
clearly inspired by this so this is the
fn 40 gl definite styling cues it's not
100 it doesn't have the latch the
textured angled foregrip is is lifted
from this so this is one of those cases
where it's inspired by it's not trying
to be this actual weapon the host weapon
and i think this is meant to be always
integrated into the weapon it's not like
an optional thing like it is on the scar
or the f-2000 which uses the same
launcher by the way the automatic rifle
assault rifle if you like it looks quite
siggy 550 series something like that
although the mags look very much like
the curved translucent textured mags
from the
cz scorpion evo 3. we've actually we
haven't got any cartridge cases coming
out of this thing i presume it's
caseless given that every every other
conventional ish weapon in the game has
country spaces coming out of it i don't
think that that can be an oversight it's
not that close to the sig but i think
that's probably the point of point of
departure for this
i don't mind if i do
the the way they've changed the grenade
launcher at the back it does have the
the wrap around the magazine well
feature of the fn40 gl the red color
with the white cross has to be
significant right so we get a blue
screen effect and the health goes up
when the grenade launcher is fired so
somehow firing a weapon at something
else heals you why not i suppose
i don't mind if i do
thanks very much for watching everyone
if you'd like to support us at the royal
armouries um you can come and visit us
if you're able to do so we have three
museums which um i know it seems like
we're showing off something else you
might be interested in if you if you are
interested in your historic firearms i'm
actually associate editor of a journal
called rmax which is actually the
journal of the kodi firearms museum over
in the us who are good friends of ours
and we are our second issue of the
revived journal because it was around in
the 90s um is coming out now so
it is paid for but it's it's for a good
cause
and there's some really good in-depth
deep dive content in there that i'm sure
be of interest to those of you who are
interested in firearms thanks very much
guys see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you